- First, the bad news.
Getting through the day can be hard.
But now the good news.
I just discovered a
beer called Stone Creek.
Now Marty, tell me more about
that problem you were having.
- Well, I was going out with my friends,
and it was nice, but everything
was just kinda "meh."
- What changed?
- Well, then we tried some beer
and things got a lot more fun.
- And you felt warm, right?
- Yeah, the warmth.
- [Man] Stone Creek beer has
the ethanol clinically proven
to raise your blood alcohol level
and get you feeling right.
- I like a cold beer at the end of the day
'cause I deserve it.
- I like it because it gives me
the confidence to talk to women.
- Is it weird that I just like the taste?
- So Marty, still worried about
a boring night out with your buddies?
- With Stone Creek beer
I don't have to worry
about a boring anything. (laughs)
(bottles clink)
- So again, you're my best friend.
- You're mine.
- Can't say it enough.
- Yeah, this is fun.